respirez moi ce bonheur les gars les
week-end promet d'être encore plus
intéressant
c'est que l'ennui assénant peut-être que
tu pourrais fermer ta gueule et tout y
est
mais avec les marques sur ton visage et
ta peau sous ses ongles on va pas [ __ ]
notre vie en l'air pour sa pièce que tu
fais pas d'après toi je reste
c'est qu'il y ait la filmer allons-y
voilà des noms
c'est fait
fait venir te chercher salvetat tandis
que kelly
c'est toi en dessous kelly mais tout ce
qu'on veut c'est ta caméra
j'ai pourtant été gentil
mais y'en a marre tu me casses les
couilles maintenant
si tu préfères que ça se passe pas là
n'oublie pas que j'ai d'abord été gentil
allez debout kelly